welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Jared AKA The Jar Jar Binks of
the heavy spoilers Universe
excited to talk all things Andor or at
least the first three episodes of this
new Star Wars series that sets up you
guessed it Rogue one a Star Wars story
oh uh you you didn't know that well well
now you do anyway in this video we're
going to discuss the general setup of
Andor some of the new characters here at
play what that ending means for the rest
of the season some potential theories of
what could happen down the road for Mr
Andor along with our general thoughts of
these first three episodes are there
going to be lightsabers do you want
lightsabers now if you enjoy this video
then please Blaster that like button and
also don't forget to subscribe to heavy
spoilers because where your only hope
for spoilers in the Galaxy with that out
of the way thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the first three
episodes of Andor
[Music]
all right so like I mentioned earlier
the character of Cassie and Endor is
featured as one of the main players in
Rogue one a Star Wars story where we see
him and his crew working for the
Rebellion task was stealing the Death
Star plans they accomplished this goal
transmitting the plans to the rebels and
then dies spoiler alert
what come on you you should know that
that happened don't don't act surprised
so with their fate not necessarily
warranting a sequel the Andor series
takes us back to the Inception of the
Cassian Endor character that we saw in
Rogue one as this series starts in the
year of bby5 at this time the Galaxy is
over Imperial control however we do see
that the Empire has almost outsourced
some of their jurisdiction to
corporations in this Show's case I guess
the planet of the morlani system are
patrolled by the pre more corporate
Authority agents essentially they are
corporate rent-a cops going through the
Daily Motions wanting to sweep things
under the rug if it's going to cause too
much of a hassle or paperwork so um the
show is definitely approaching the
corrupted power angle in an interesting
manner anyway this is very much a
younger inexperienced technical but a
bit sloppy Cassian than what we saw in
Rogue one he is that scoundrel type pull
in different jobs owing multiple people
credits hanging around scummy underworld
establishments he has an attitude of
sticking it to the Empire stealing from
the rich fat pigs that they are because
they are too arrogant to think that
anyone would ever try to cross them the
framework of what he becomes in Rogue
one is very much present now aside from
Cassian these first three episodes
introduce us to a handful of other
characters that may be in the play for
the rest of the series either helping
Cassian hunting him down or potentially
a combination of the two the most
influential so far being the new
character of surreal Carn Karn appears
to be this boy scout type Deputy
inspector for the corporate Authority
seem to have you know made his own
alterations to his uniform he is
organized plays it by the book wants to
climb the ranks but does have this kind
of Innocence to him when talking with
Sergeant Linus we see him agree with
taking more of an aggressive approach to
patrolling these planets in the sector
very much like what we know the Empire
to be in Star Wars but he completely
cowards in the face of actual field work
and the casualties that come with it Bix
Colleen seems to be an old friend of
Cassian potentially a love interest at
some point in their lives with her
having a bit of a questionable past as
well working at a salvage yard she has
contacts who smuggle in and out goods
and also skims credits off the top here
or there Marva Andor is the adoptive
mother of Cassian she appears to be this
compassionate mother but then again does
have a questionable past smuggling and
looting of her own in the earlier years
we see her looting a crashed Galactic
Republic freighter on the planet of
kanare where she meets a young Cassian
or rather Casa at that time there is
also b2emo or B2 for short that is a
salvage assistant ground Mech even
though it's a Droid I gotta say it does
have a quirky personality and does care
for the Andor family quite a bit and
lastly luthin in real who turns up to be
the buyer that Cassian is trying to
unload the untraceable ns9 star path
unit with luthin has a bit of a Mystique
about him can he be trusted is he an
Imperial spy so far we aren't entirely
sure but either way we know he has some
Deep Pockets offering to buy the star
path unit from Cassian but also does see
something else in him offering Cassian a
way out of his troubles but there is
something he needs from him first now
these first three episodes honestly play
together like one big origin story movie
covering how a young Cassian came to be
from where he is now and the journey
that I'm assuming sets him on the path
to what he becomes that we saw in Rogue
one and the ending is playing out both
of these stories at once in the current
timeline the corporate Authority agents
are hot on the trail of Cassian as he
meets with luthin about selling the star
path unit through this conversation
though Lutheran discovers Andor can be
utilized for much more offering to get
him off off the planet if he helps with
something now Lutheran seems a bit vague
about what this is but with us knowing
Rogue one takes place roughly five years
after this something tells me that
Lutheran is recruiting Cassian for the
beginning of what we eventually see are
the rebels even going back to what
Sergeant Linus said there are Pockets
fermenting meaning that small groups of
people are attempting to rise up against
them it's fermenting
pockets of fermenting and this is even
seen a couple times in episode 3 with
all of the townspeople banging on the
metal to distract the corpos while
cassian's friend straight-up ties
Salvage to one of their attack pods
causing it to crash we're seeing the
seeds of the Rebellion form and I'm
positive Lutheran has recruited cassin
for this cause but whether it be a rogue
one-esque job is kind of Beyond me I
could see them headed out to the outer
rim you know somewhere where it's a bit
safer as for Lutheran himself I want to
say that he's a wealthy benefactor or
potentially politician in the same vein
as Bale Organa wanting to end the
Imperial rule much like others there is
an inkling that he could be in an
Imperial spy and there's some Mission
Impossible mask reveal gotcha moment but
as of now I'd say that that is a long
shot never tell me the odds while the
devastation witnessed by Karn is
probably going to drive him down the
path of aggression even more as this
season plays out his story arc is going
to be this officer of the law molded
into a blinded power hungry Imperial
officer that is definitely going to be a
thorn in Cassie inside as this story
plays out as for the flashback timeline
Marva is seen rescuing Cassian as a boy
from the republic ships approaching the
crash site this helps to explain how he
got off of ferric's why the name change
why this birthplace of kanari was such a
big deal and why Cassian has been
searching for his sister this whole time
they were separated that day because she
stayed back at the campsite while
Cassian ended up going on the hunt for
all we know she could have been wiped
out by the Republic forces that were
coming to the crash site or she thinks
that Cassian ended up dying that day now
it's a little theater
did
it
yeah I have to pay Paul five dollars to
use that Sounder so I hope it's worth it
but what a twist of fate it would be
that at the end of this season Cassian
is firmly implanted on the path of
becoming the rebel that we see in Rogue
one only to find out that after pulling
off this Lutheran job that his sister is
still alive and is a well-established
Imperial officer what a shocker that
would be if that was the season one
Cliffhanger let me know in nine-ish
weeks whether or not it's right because
this may be your reaction when the
season finale happens
overall I am really digging this Andor
series it genuinely feels like an
immersive ground level dirty dingy crime
Thriller pulling in several different
characters which I'm hoping each play
into the central story while exploring
their own story lines and build out the
Star Wars World much more than hey look
at that thing or remember that thing or
that character this feels new and
honestly brings Star Wars back to what I
remember it being as a kid especially
the musical score setting the tone of
everything sure the Mandalorian had some
great moments but Andor is the first
time that since maybe like Rogue one
that I have felt like oh this this is
something special and the fact that they
used practical sets rather than the big
volume screens used for the Mandalorian
and the Book of Boba Fett makes it feel
that much more real yeah yeah I guess
real if that makes sense it just feels
like the characters and everything are
actually there and I'm excited to see
where for these 12 episodes take us
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the first three episodes of Andor and
is this a solid return back to the Star
Wars World anyway we're currently
running a competition giving away three
copies yes three of Thor love and
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do for a chance to win this
is like this video make sure to
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below on your thoughts of
Andor we picked the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so if that's you message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos right over
there whether it be our house of dragon
breakdowns or Rick and Morty season 6
coverage with that out of the way thanks
for sticking through this video I've
been Jared and some replaced you made it
this far I'll see in the next one take
care and peace